you're watching the Valley's most
accurate forecast on 8 News Now
Heather would you like the weather
clicker I gotta go get a 70 Cent donut
I think I've got time to get there after
the show so we still have a we have a
little bit of haze going on but that is
going to get blown out of here over the
next couple of days it's a great view
from our camera on top of the Red Rock
Resort and yes when you drive by look up
on the roof there's a paltry hanging out
up there you can see the strip and yeah
a little bit of brown officially 54
degrees at Reid International but we
always want to check your neighborhood
look at that hanging on to the upper 40s
in Summerlin Mountain's Edge close to 60
is the warm spot at the Air Force Base
54 downtown 55 along the strip all of
these numbers about 10 degrees below
where we normally would be when we get
into the middle of November checking to
Nevada and Beyond not even 70 in Death
Valley low 50s over the hunt in prompt
been getting down to the teens up in Ely
you're at 30 right now it's below the
freezing Mark just barely above freezing
in Cedar City so we're going to try for
58 today again about 10 degrees below
normal low this morning at 40 not quite
10 degrees below normal and temperatures
really are not going to be moving a
whole lot over the next several days so
the next system is already pushing
onshore in the Pacific Northwest that's
where the first round of wind is going
to come from and then look at this baby
this is a classic counterclockwise
pinwheel rotation that is more wind for
later on in the week oh we want to check
in on your family and friends all over
the country yes this is snow falling in
parts of Nebraska Kansas and Oklahoma
otherwise it is rain through much of
East Texas Louisiana now moving into
Arkansas and of course some of that snow
moving into the Upper Midwest I mean
it's not winter but we're getting close
here is your most accurate eight day
forecast the wind picks up later today
and continues most of the day tomorrow
we're talking about gusts to 35 miles an
hour maybe 60 and possibly working our
way to 62 by Friday when the next round
of winds come comes in but we're still
not talking about any rain and overnight
lows dipping into this the 30s in many
neighborhoods Heather boy that is going
to be chilly all right